this form a language now that uh might
be somewhere between a mix of AI and uh
something else
slurred it's just getting lazy man
slanglish sling English
what we've noticed is that uh stable
diffusion is getting better at actually
spitting out letters yeah well the new
XL one right that's yeah
Dean's been messing around with it today
making funny movies it's not it's not
sputtering out gibberish letters anymore
it's actually
um starting to put together
somewhat correct form letters in English
which is great
yeah it's great news for the AI not for
us
that's great for them I thought it was
just got confused about like putting
Russian
letters into English it has and that's
that's what it felt like that's what it
was doing before this
time but uh you know now it appears to
be getting better its English is getting
better so yeah
and it was trained or something I don't
know probably who knows what do you mean
you're putting things in quotes but like
we'd put like the title that we want it
to write and of course and it gets it
most of the way there oh yeah
like Titanic and it got like an extra T
and it like replaced an eye with a t but
it's generally you know what it's trying
to do next results yeah
oh yeah yeah but so it's just like it's
like it's still just like uh like a
gumball machine or you know like those
those like sticker machines from back in
the day where it's like it's like 25
cents for this like goofy trinket and
you you're like yeah this is cool and
then you basically throw it away
remember how popular those popular those
were outside of restaurants and stuff
yeah it was like remember I was about to
say homies homies oh my god did you guys
collect all the homies I did not collect
all the homies but we used to do the
stickers and they used to every
restaurant in the 90s and early 2000s I
swear like I had the sticker parents
would pay and then they'd be walking out
and you know you know they got the
quarter they know they got the quarter
so you're in the lobby it would be like
where you either waited to go into the
restaurant or the door you went through
as you were leaving and every kid had to
ask whether or not they could get one of
those janky stickers mom can I get a
homie yeah dude I got homies and tattoos
and slime hands those are my hands
Brothers slime pants are still great
yeah they're still great dude there
still is a market for those kinds of
goods it's just a platform called Teemu
and you can get all that you want yeah
you can get slime hands and mass whoa
yes have you seen them running ads on uh
on
YouTube's like a trying to be a
competitor to Amazon but it's like even
more janky than Amazon and their ads are
done in Ai and it's like where's this on
the scale of wish is this like below
yeah that's a good story it's right
there it's right there okay
um and it's like a modern version of one
of those little vending machines when
you go it's like yeah pay us uh like a
pittance and we'll send you garbage yeah
yeah yeah it's it's not quite like um a
like a betting site or like where you
you know there's some sites I don't know
if that's how wish works but it's like
is that the one where you wish it's just
basically just like a dumpster
dumpster yeah and there's a troll in
there that'll trade you the assets of
the dumpster for like four dollars okay
okay I I have not had the pleasure of
visiting wish yet so um it's excited
I'll avoid that as long as I can but I
don't know
once you visit You'll wish you hadn't
that's the slogan
I mean if we're we're talking about you
know quality items here the homies just
to bring it back real quick oh yeah yeah
everyone's talking about if I could go
back in time yeah I tell my younger self
to buy Bitcoin no I'm telling myself to
buy the homies collection are they 29
brother 29 on eBay for a 100 wow okay
that's that's about 350 per figure
that's originally 25 cents that's up
13.7 times
that's an investment dude you could have
had a home that's not bad that's not bad
I mean it depends on how long ago you
bought it though you know I guess but if
you have a portfolio Diversified between
you know Bond stocks
portfolio
wow dude I I would always get this one
wheelchair homie dude and I he was like
my curse dude the wheelchair an odd
because of the wheelchair it's just
[Applause]
why are you dwelling on the quadriplegic
mix
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know what I like to think of though
is that someone out there does have the
most homies like someone has that title
I don't know who it is or how many they
have but someone has the most and that's
weird in one box where are you at make
the video yeah tell us
probably somebody who has an outstanding
homies collection you know they've got
like homies in espanol they've got like
the you know all the Japanese version
special edition
yeah they have the only quadriplegic
homie too like they have the full set
[Laughter]
honestly dude yeah those toys taught me
about La culture yeah
dude there's all these different types
of homies right oh wow wide range the
last one is graduating college that's
the last time he's holding up a diploma
for 2002. he did man he did it made it
dude made it
wow yeah but now the gang's after him oh
my God yeah they don't like it he's got
that education they want him back in now
with those skills
to run this business yes they need a
marketing man there should be a movie
about homies the homies man yeah bring
it back the homies
animated with uh Charlie Day
it comes yeah yeah oh my God
no oh man no shame yeah though
oh god oh wow homies man well soon we
all might just be emojis because
apparently
they're gonna replace actors oh yeah did
you hear about that yeah I heard about
this yeah I heard that they're all going
to be replaced
yeah all of them that wasn't yeah that
was an interesting conversation me and
ren uh did a video just I guess it would
be out this this weekend
or past weekend just came out a couple
days just came out just came out a
couple days ago uh about yeah how far
away are we realistically from replacing
actors with full CG and I'm still in the
camp that it's like you know it's really
really really hard to do
and there's like right you gotta be
99.99 I mean even that's not enough so
it's for me it just economically doesn't
make any sense I don't know I mean also
like let's be honest too it's like of
all the strikes and stuff that are
happening right now you know like
there's all these intricacies that are
going into it with like the history of
the film industry and streaming services
and all these arguments about like oh
like are they releasing the real numbers
like should we be getting residuals like
there's all this like real tangible
stuff here but for some reason the
Nugget that people are sifting through
like the one that sticks after everyone
sits through these arguments is AI which
I mean maybe that's the it's like it's
the most recognizable talking point but
frankly I would say is like kind of like
the least relevant aspect of whatever
nobody even knows what it is right what
is it AI what the hell is it AI what's
even mean by that but also like truly
let's be honest like what's having more
of an effect on livelihoods of these
people well not is it AI or is it they
acknowledge like I think people are very
misinformed about how much AI is
actually has anything to do with these
the strikes going on like I literally
read through you can go on the website
you can read their list of things this
is why we're striking it has what why
they're striking and then it has a list
of grievances yes literally there's it's
it's like a long document you should
read it yeah listen our grievances when
we separated from a little section is AI
and I agree with what they're trying to
get they're trying to say you know you
can't scan us and then like replace us
basically well that's the interesting
part about it it's not even really AI
like yeah people are saying they've been
doing Digi doubles for years yes it's
labeled as artificial intelligence and
then it goes on to talk about you know
like including AI you can't scan us and
then you know use our likenesses
indefinitely yeah what they were saying
on on the SAG after website and again
like this is this is their translation
of the negotiation so I'm sure put on
your rose tinted super like I'm sure
it's gonna be I mean even though their
verbiage on there is like we asked for
this they said no way no like the way
that they're describing it isn't like I
wish they would have put the real
response let's just be you know yeah
strict about this stuff but it's like
when your friend tells you about drama
and you're like you can't expect that in
this type of it wouldn't it be great
though but you have to well it would be
great just 350 million American citizens
just hard working and doing the right
thing how about that
yeah what they were saying was they're
trying to get in front of this whole AI
thing from the perspective from their
from their perspective what they were
saying is they were being offered a half
day rate in exchange for being digitally
scanned to be used in the full capacity
of the movie in any context without
consent and then in any future project
which is I guess where the AI Factor
comes in well and also to be training AI
models to generate more digital humans
to be fed into the machine but I heard
from the other side too it's like well
no it's more just for the scope of this
film so I don't know where the truth is
like a film studio or a VFX house like
you should be going out there and hiring
people to make your data sets and paying
people specifically for that I think I
think that's totally reasonable that's
totally fair I I mean I don't see the
problem with that explicitly I mean
obviously if you're trying to sneak it
into a contract yeah like here's a
standard day rate for something and then
also now that all this new technology
exists let's tack on maybe this headshot
and then the photo scan and maybe even
film you walking it's like a walk cycle
it's like okay yeah obviously now you're
just asking for more work you're trying
to make it so well yeah yeah I guess
it's more work but it's more for me like
that's if I'm an actor and they're photo
scanning me and then you know they have
the ability to recruit me say they do
yeah I guess so then they don't have to
call me back to set up yeah exactly then
they don't need to if there's a sequel
and they want you know this character
act or whatever depending on the rights
of that yeah that guy did really well
with the audience so let's put them on
the bus in the Marvel movie and let's
just like add this 3D model of him yeah
this is a real version did so well yeah
this this thing will happen and this
like miximo animation well it's gonna
it's gonna do yeah it's gonna be Bonkers
they kind of yeah they kind of already
do that
in many ways I mean look at what
happened with JC with with our our
Jordan Coleman when she went and did the
uh Zack Snyder thing what happened like
they brought her down there for a couple
of days and then she was a
she had a non-speaking character role I
believe it was like a featured heavily
featured extra yeah
they took all the extra features in the
thumbnails they got from her and she's
like in the main marketing now of the
piece because because Snyder really
liked the English character yeah because
she just got these crazy horns and she's
got this crazy outfit on and it's like
it's really wild imagery so I get why
that is but it's not like she got paid
any extra but that was I mean that is
part of the deal yeah yeah and it's kind
of messed up that there's no like
retroactive like hey like we ended up
using you for our marketing campaign
well it's never been well I don't know
at the same time that's the whole point
of the set that's the film shoot it's
like they do a shoot and then they're
like man this one shot turned out really
well and the cinematographer can't be
like hey well you know I put extra work
into that shot you know you should pay
me more to use that for the DVD you know
yeah it becomes this is comes this like
exactly it's like it becomes impossible
to articulate money at a certain point
yeah now I do get I do get that there's
a clear distinction between hey we used
you in a bunch of marketing assets from
stuff that we shot while we paid you to
be here and do this thing versus hey we
made a bunch of marketing assets from a
single time that you were here and now
we've taken that and done this with it
so there is an obvious distinction for
that uh
yeah now how that gets worked out I mean
I think the demands are totally fair
what they're asking for it and there
should probably even be more like you
know contractual obligations to really
lock down what you're signing away well
that's the thing we don't want to go
sign away my my photo scan yeah
definitely and that's the thing is like
that already the discrepancy that I'm
hearing of it being in perpetuity
forever versus just for the project or
it's a half day rate or no it's not it's
more than that like I guess you know us
being on the outside we can't see the
exact terms that they're discussing but
I mean I think it's very wise of them to
try and get in front of it contractually
just say okay let's at least shine a
light on this everyone be aware that
this is going on know what your price is
know what you're willing to give it up
for but at the end of the day yeah just
come up with a flat rate for if you're
going to give your name and likeness to
that particular IP or that particular
feature or that particular show
come up with a flat rate for that yeah
yeah and then and just you know or have
contingencies have a flat rate and then
have contingencies if it goes into a
iterations or whatever I'm sure that
their lawyers are more than capable of I
think so
coming up with these things yeah but
um yeah I do think there's a little bit
of
things being blown out of proportion
which you can obviously imagine is you
know a pretty good tactic during this
kind of period where it's like okay
you know feeding information that's not
100 the truth on both sides is probably
a tactic I'm sure well yeah and like and
then like these blanket terms get used
and like in the context of this strike
and the contract that they're asking for
AI is definitely coming into play right
but then you can't apply it now to
anyone using AI tools for anything is
now going against sag-aftra yeah yeah
excuse me like there's no logic there
yeah like these are completely different
tools yeah I know it's just like the
it's the dumb dumb approach it's like
incredibly one person is striking and AI
is somewhere in the list so now blanket
statement anyone using AI is uh against
the strike I guess oh yeah no totally
against it have you guys heard that and
also have you read the comments of anime
rock paper scissors that's the updated
version of all the negatives I was
expecting an anime videos you guys are
you know I can't believe this is such
poor taste this is an Abomination you
guys are terrible for like going against
everything they're striking for oh
because the actors were in
um yeah no that's not correlated guys
six to eight people made this over the
course of five months yeah well we
continued to iterate and use and develop
experimental technology that's that's
what happened
but so dumb you know yeah I think that's
because there's this sense this
sensationalism going on where people can
it's like here's all these complicated
words that describe why they're striking
and then someone says Ai and they're
like oh AI that's bad
I get it this is oh yeah
yeah like say wait yeah it's like that's
really good and you ask him to explain
what exactly is an AI program I honestly
dude talking to anyone that I know who's
striking a lot of people I know no one's
mentioned AI there's been no talk about
it interesting yeah
yeah exactly real life like actual
things that matter have they mentioned
the digital scanning aspect because
obviously that's that's apart from the
AI side which is using that scan to
train models whatever but the actual
scanning of yeah that's been mentioned
but yeah not in an AI sense not like
they're gonna then you know train data
sets on us
um I don't know I mean there's certainly
a lot of people that are hyper aware of
that but I don't think most people are
aware of that yeah I think it's mostly
about like the digi double concern and
the you know yeah the I guess yeah for
20 years 30 years still yeah they've
already been replacing all crowds are
digitally replaced all you know War
scenes for the most part are digitally
replaced it's no liability for you know
imagine trying to do like the Battle of
Helms Deep with people yeah
Game of Thrones do the battle of the
bastards without CG yeah
yeah they
you just can't do that scene Without You
utilizing CG and that's there's no shame
in that it's not unless it's like a
snuff film otherwise you become like the
freaking guy from speed two the director
who had to direct I forget his name
who had to do this scene and was
probably like in spite of he was spiting
the production because they did an
ending scene in this movie that is still
to this day the most expensive action
scene ever done yeah dude it was crazy
25 million dollars in 90s money
a five-minute scene of a boat crashing
into a dock oh it's beautiful 25 million
dollars it's so beautiful yeah I am glad
he did it I'm very glad he could have
been hired with that money but that's
that's what you get when you can't use
CG that's what you mean they did it
really yeah those were all hired
buildings local buildings yeah local
pretty cool man no it's interesting
because you know the conversation too is
about like how achievable is it and what
was interesting was we had Guy Williams
from weather on the couch recently and
he was showing us some stuff from Gemini
man yeah
man I apologize I always get those mixed
up please but uh he was showing us some
clips there where there was a full CG
Will Smith not Young Will Smith but
normal age Will Smith and I could not
tell yeah could not tell like front
facing two camera acting I can't
remember if there's dialogue or not
because that's usually a tell with the
lip motion but totally passable but then
you ask the question okay fooled me good
well very well done but then you look at
Avatar and they're very vocal in
explaining that 10 seconds of facial
animation took between three to four
weeks to do yeah so you go wait but
that's just a take that you could get
with somebody and then you can instantly
feedback and go well try it like this or
try it like that and get some
performance and get some uh something
original out of them as well and you
just start to wonder like okay
financially does it make any sense will
it ever make it does it make sense if
you just need Will Smith to be Will
Smith yeah like yeah it does it might
make sense if you need Will Smith to
play an alien creature yeah sure sure an
Avatar Planet Avatar 2 being the
examiner you have to you have to replace
their face
with the character that they're playing
but yeah as far as just like actual
actors on camera
well I mean to us it seems like and but
like probably in a couple years it will
be viable my question is say you can
perfectly replicate you know young hair
say you can say say we can get Harrison
Ford to play as many young Indiana
Joneses as we want we'll be fighting
Nazis forever
would people even care
it's an interesting question nope it's
an interesting answer they won't care
just about that not well this is the
question we were talking about
novelty yeah where it's something that's
like oh we're going to see this because
I heard they made them young like of
course you're not gonna care they're
well that's the most will ever care but
when you see it you're like I instantly
don't care this is yeah I mean I think
right now every big franchise has proven
that there's an end to everything you
know what I'm saying like Star Wars
Indiana Jones what what else you know I
mean there's Avengers Marvel there's
like uh there's like a life cycle to
this stuff and the reason it's special
was because of the the time and place
and how it's created and you know the
the society it's released into the
specific you know cultural elements
happening there and so it's like okay
cool now you want to reboot it 30 years
later or heck just keep making it
indefinitely it's like
what what else like General Hospital
yeah is like kind of like one of those
like examples General Hospital season no
like there's the examples of this
concept of indefinitely you know are are
so few and far between that I feel like
I don't know yeah I mean I I guess yeah
if you're being scanned it's like a
background character for digital doubles
sure like those main characters for a
long time but yeah because I mean people
are concerned I think it's like our
actors going to be out of jobs but like
it's like probably not so much of an
actor's like an actor's success is so
driven by their real life celebrity
still you know their real life Persona
and like people enjoy seeing like people
that they can look relate to in some
facet like yeah you know quote unquote
nice funny
Chris Pratt you know like that's why he
gets a lot of the roles too it's like
sure he's funny on screen but also it's
just like he seems to be like a you know
a happy-go-lucky Persona and when you
see that on screen and you're aware of
that you're like okay you know oh
totally I can bear watching this person
for two hours I think honestly
stuff now where it's like you know once
again let's watch a Kevin Spacey movie
and like tell me how much you can really
enjoy the narrative this fictional
fantasy world knowing you know all the
wacky grooming [__] to you he's excuses
and stuff you know so I think I mean it
does make sense why those scenes that he
did in House of Cards are so real
because to him
that was just him being yeah he has real
life inspiration to draw from right they
hid the cameras on sets the whole time
so it's it's that but that feels like
you're watching a smut film it feels
like you're watching somebody like die
on camera for real
it doesn't feel right to watch but it
makes the scene
good
you know what's crazy I heard about it
as if I told you guys this so I heard
about Kevin Spacey when I was doing
child acting did I ever tell you this oh
boy I mean no it's it's a short story
but I was in I was in a trailer
no no no no I've never met the man thank
God but I was I was a child actor I was
like 11 12 something like that and I was
in a trailer doing whatever and then I
don't even remember who it was but I
remembering them mentioning Kevin Spacey
and saying we're lucky he's not on set
as a joke
but I didn't fully comprehend it as a
kid oh my God but then when it came out
about Kevin Spacey it like triggered the
memory again I was like oh shoot so this
is like a known thing okay well that's
uncomfortable maybe some actors of
course it was a no that's the thing yeah
it's always a known thing sure sure it's
always a known thing but to people that
know that person
and they make excuses and they cover it
up and everyone knows it's wrong but
people don't have enough ability whether
that's moral or financial or just like
balls to do it because if they do it
means their career or if they do it
means you know no work for you baby boo
well you know that's important
successful why this stuff goes on for so
long
I mean it's an interesting parallel to
what we're talking about too is like
taking someone's digital Essence there
is the idea of look I know you want to
be on you know you want to get into the
industry you want to be doing background
work it's like part of that has given up
your digital Essence it's part of the
contract it's all normal and obviously
without the union side of it you're kind
of subject to that kind of bullying so
you know I get I I'm kind of in favor of
them getting in front of this as much as
they can because oh totally it is going
to be a very interesting yeah
like looking past that though like let's
forget extras and background actors like
fun they're gonna get replaced they
already have been like the conclusion we
draw from the video is essentially they
probably all anyone who's not a
principal actor will probably
in many cases not Beyond set yes it gets
cheaper and cheaper to do it not as many
days not as many yeah that's not
surprising and like sure like yeah it's
gonna hurt the industry I mean maybe
those jobs will be made up by more VFX
artists or whatever right
but I'm talking about principal actors
like
I don't think they have anything to
worry about yeah I mean I mean what like
what's like
I mean I feel like right now
everyone like principal actors have
already like I think kind of ironed out
their contracts pretty well when it
comes to digital likenesses and
everything like that you know you look
at like oh you know all those shots that
require a digital double of your actor
it's like
they are constructing that for that one
film
and then they generally like redo and
even like in sequels they'll update it
redo it so and so forth and it's always
on a per film basis from yeah my you
know naive knowledge of it but well
that's what you should be doing if
you're if you're they're
entertainmentally so if you're their
entertainment lawyer that's what you
should be doing
well there's there's also the aspect of
it that comes down to Performance as
well for an actor and you know we've
said it before but AI is derivative
and you're not going to get anything
unique out of it at least not in this
stage I don't know how they would
develop on that but you know I always
point to uh Heath Ledger right in Dark
Knight like no one would have thought to
play The Joker like that that was such a
unique spin on it and it was so iconic
that it stood out and it like connected
to all of us and still lives on it it's
a really interesting point that uh Josh
Newland made in the BTS of the uh anime
rock paper scissors 2 episode which was
exactly that it's these tools are only
iterative so if you really want to use
them to their full capacity
of what they truly can do you need to
constantly be shaping them with new data
new information and and new new visuals
that they haven't seen before yeah of
course with enough machine learning
enough iterations it'll start to spit at
you
you know like
Novelties quote but
[Music]
I don't know if there's any
like comparison for human ability with
respect to that I I don't know
well that's what I keep saying to people
because I think for all this stuff
whether it's background actors main
actors being replaced not the
conversation isn't even really about Ai
No right it's more about like will VFX
be good enough to replace Brad Pitt
right talking to the Rock and they're
not even there on set I like how they're
mad at VFX now we'll talk about that in
a second yeah I mean everyone's just
getting looped together because no one
really knows what's going on but
it's like okay
so you're scared that they're gonna
like Photo scan a celebrity
and like capture their Essence and just
keep putting out these these projects
that star these people who are maybe
long dead it's like the people get so
scared about these these little moments
of quick advance in fact I mean it
always happens but and then they
extrapolate it too oh dude now actors
aren't going to be a thing now movies
aren't going to be a thing people aren't
gonna you know connect it's like no at
the end of the day like humans want to
see other humans Being Human like if you
told me it say this Tech was already
around and like
a studio comes out and they're like this
new movie starring Robert Redford and
Marilyn Monroe is coming out
I'd be like who Robert Redford that's
that old guy right it's like
celebrity is also generational too yeah
so what's your representative
essentially yeah so I mean then it goes
to characters right so Indiana Jones is
a character I guess you could Market
young Harrison Ford world where you a
couple Generations away from that one
you know and they're still trying to
Market them and we saw how kind of how
that went so already like it shows me
like people don't really care like they
want people from their generation they
want the celebrity that they think is
cool like Disney you can clone Harrison
Ford all you want or Island and they
want they want their own IP too it's
like whether it's a live horse or a CG
horse if it's dead and you keep beating
it No One's Gonna care it's like Star
Wars people grew up on that it was so
exciting at the time and it spoke to
that generation
that has continued on it's I mean I'm
not interested in it personally anymore
I mean I never really was but but like
that's what I'm talking about is like it
had its moment and it died out and now
it's time for a new idea or a new IP
that speaks to this generation and
whatever it is it has to happen
organically
yeah how
like prolific
just social media celebrities have
become I mean of course you have like
everyone that is part of this
there was a guy in New York City the
other day that like started a riot over
a PlayStation giveaway
yeah yeah you want to hear about this no
it's crazy yeah
and then it was like a riot
yeah there's literally a riot they're in
the city of New York is literally
charging it with inciting a riot Miss
felony levels of yeah what's what
sparked it was it he just didn't show up
or Playstation giveaway oh he was there
giving him away and then everyone's
fighting for him hey
hey one PlayStation yeah a PlayStation
giveaway who wants it yeah no I mean but
it's not it's not about that's my point
isn't about the specifics of that
circumstance my point is that
that is exactly the same reaction that
people
are having towards this person as they
had uh to The Beatles in 1965.
like it's it's the same level of
Hysteria because yeah for this
generation
right right exactly yeah but but it's
it's more like broken down and localized
now and I don't know if that's
necessarily a bad thing because it means
the propaganda machines and and
everything else can't quite do the same
type of work they used to do because you
can't even more sinisterly because
they're all wrapped up but that's right
that's that's the other side of it too
is you can wrap people up they're silent
but deadly bro like
now dude who smells like you know what
I'm saying no just like these
Sensational these like like the the
celebrity is now it's less widespread
it's less you know it's more it's more
localized localized yeah honestly to who
you are and what you like and you know I
mean whatever everyone knows we're
rolling our own Bubbles and everyone's
in the bubble we'll see this is not your
own bubble celebrities this is the
actual AI conversation to be totally
honest I think this is I've thought
about so many iterations of this at this
point this is our
30th 40th 50th podcast about this topic
oh yeah I'd say we've done a few but
like you know it's mostly just because
you you listen to a lot of arguments
about okay what is this actually gonna
do is this just a job stealer you know I
mean and maybe yeah sure it's you could
say it's a job stealer but you'd say
it's a job stealer in the sense that
like a personal computer could
potentially eliminate uh typewriter
manufacturing jobs you know there's like
yeah so sure so it's true in that sense
but then if you think about there's
another element which is okay uh what if
you live in a world now where anyone can
create content basically you know it's
so this is like you know and this is
something that then starts to basically
affect what we're doing because we're
already I mean you know we have a large
following you know there's a lot of
people who watch our videos and we've
been doing it for a long time we're
pretty established in the space But even
still within the grand scheme of things
here
um like the amount of content has been
so Diversified and so democratized to
the point where you know the amount of
yeah everyone's got a profile page watch
hours you know and all that stuff that
are happening now and like how people's
attention has spread out over the course
of the last 30 years since the internet
has taken hold
um you know it's already very very
deluded and granted you know we
ourselves and a lot of other people out
there who are filming and doing comedy
and being personalities like sure
there's uh there's a skill usually
associated with that
um in some form or another but what I
see this AI doing is basically making it
so now we've basically hit another step
of dilution effectively and I'm using
dilution it's kind of a negative word I
would say no it's
it's like once again I don't want to
make it I mean it's only negative when
you think about it from like someone
like ourselves or another small even a
smaller Creator like from that
perspective it's solution it's negative
um but like truly what it does allow for
is that
that next step here of
content that is even easier to produce
than what we're making and anyone can do
it and so I it's it's really for me a
matter of like this concept of the
future of a totally different balance
between Creator consumer when it comes
to the content
um and and I think that's that's the
that's the weird area there because I
you go you you can also Circle it back
to the whole argument about
AI freeing up more time for people to
make art you know if you've heard that
one right that one gets bounced around
or a lot where it's like oh it will
increase efficiency so you know
magically more people will have more
free time to do things and it's like
well
no probably most likely definitely no
because if anyone is going to be using
that AI it's it's coming from a top-down
perspective so to speak like anyone
who's trying to run anything
whether it's us making a YouTube channel
or an accountant or a bank or whatever
like if the can you utilize the AI first
what that does immediately as we started
with this conversation with is it then
we'll remove jobs you know it removes
certain positions the types of people
that are needed for things so it's less
of a oh it'll free me up to make art
more often it's like no actually it's
going to free up the person who hired
you
to make more art
because they are able to do more with
less now but yeah then then the final
step is for the job the final step is
everything obviously will then expand
and contract and then rebalance itself
out to whatever new economy that shapes
into look I I emphasize or sorry I
emphasize I emphasize the empathy of the
with the artists okay like I yeah it
sucks to be
feeling the part of capitalism where the
industry outpaces what you currently do
in the industry that happens to a lot of
sectors and now it's hitting the
entertainment industry hard
so we're seeing that because the
entertainment industry is in front of
everyone and it's affecting my Netflix
so I care about it more than when it
happens yeah the aeronaut or the
Aerospace industry or the car and we'll
just wait till all the call centers get
wiped out that's gonna happen pretty
soon like every you know however many
hundreds of thousands of people who just
literally answer phones for a living
like we've already managed to cut off
how about there's the jobs with like all
the other robotic options and semi semi
AI stuff how about like the sweatshops
of animators over in India that are
hired by all of the US companies over in
Hollywood over there to do most of the
work for like not a good wage like all
of them they're gonna feel it but is
that like is that the Pinnacle of
Animation is that where we want this
industry to be like exploiting people
already
I don't know is that worth saving like
just the mass Expo exploitation of other
countries for America yeah
shooting someone to put them out of
their misery no I'm not advocating for
it I'm just saying like people like I
see this like idealized in anything
there's this ideal but like this
idealized version of the animation
industry like it's like dude perfect and
animation industry are [__] brutal
for everyone I think you do need to pump
the brakes a little bit on this idea of
saying that like every single time a
company in Hollywood goes out to a third
world country and hires a team of
rotoscopers or you know plate animators
or whatever it is is exploitation of
them as well because a lot of times
those jobs aren't available but for
the companies that brought them there
and a lot of times the wages that they
pay are far above the average living
wage for what it is in that country and
there's this very American and
westernized perspective that people have
which is just to go you're paying them
how much oh that's like slave labor back
back breaking labor but in those
countries it's actually a a double what
you could get doing something that's far
more arduous and laborious and so I I
just I know that there's an agreement
that's on the other side of that which
is why you could just say that about
everything
no no it does stimulate a lot of job
growth and there's a ton of opportunity
provided by these countries but my
original point in even going over there
to that subject was to say that it is
not that a a business is
responsibility to create jobs I'm sorry
it is not right and like yeah this whole
like these student like I don't think
it's a good thing that Studios and these
like massive corporations with all their
shareholders who are at the will of
those shareholders are taking any
opportunity they can including going
overseas and putting people over here
out of jobs they have been for years but
no no you're right no they don't have an
obligation they've already been doing
that well I mean so talking about this
strike thing here a little bit a little
more you're right though it's like it's
not the when it comes to Ai and what
we're talking about here with it and
even just digital doubles likeness
whatever blah blah yeah it's not the
Studio's job to
or sorry it's not a company's job like a
film studio
to create jobs so to speak you must be
inefficient literally they exist for one
purpose and that is to make a product
and sell it exactly and it's not to hire
but that being said I do believe though
that it is a company's
job to oversee and like basically uh I
guess guarantee the well-being the
financial well-being of the people who
are dedicating their full-time
absolutely hours that's that's the
actual problem right there Sam that's an
actual problem you have to have both
those things in mind if you're gonna
actually enter into this well and so
that's this is also super it's even
trickier because basically Hollywood is
a gig industry as well like even with
writers you know like certain writers
that like become like writers of a show
it's now full time but the moment like
if you're even just like like a film
writer you know like what that's you
know that's you're just hoping that the
paycheck from one script lasts you until
the next one you know and like even with
background characters yeah extras or
with all these highest paid actors in
the game that's all still a gig
exactly exactly and so I think it's just
it's that that muddies that conversation
so much when you realize that um but I
don't know I saw so I I mean I don't
have like the my the best fully formed
opinion on on that particular
argument because well like I don't know
the ins and outs but I do know that like
these companies are losing so much money
trying to keep these streaming services
competitive
a feeling that that probably is playing
into why everyone's getting so teo'd um
yeah no I mean they're trying to like
just make so much stuff and I mean
that's crazy isn't that why the writer
started striking originally because it
was like they aren't even seeing the
same uh residuals they're pushing the
prices down
to get more and their contracts based on
residuals from traditional television
and that's not enough now they have D
they're they're writing for things that
are going straight to streaming and the
contract doesn't cover that because it's
on streaming rather than on TV it's it's
stupid and it should have been figured
out and I get why that that that's
history as as the you know as the the
owners of a streaming service
technically ourselves yeah like there is
residuals on a streaming service and
that happens once a month you know yeah
like that that's that's the whole thing
it's like it's there is this it's it's a
it's a stream it's a constant you know
it's just we haven't gotten to the point
of sophistication with them yet where uh
you can like really figure out the
analytics and the compensation based on
that but maybe that's where all this
needs to go I mean and then you have
this other problem which Sam you just
pointed out which is all the streaming
services are trying to basically under
undercut each other right now and
produce a ton of stuff and that's just
leading to this race to the bottom yeah
okay here's every sector of the industry
too they're undercutting the filmmakers
also well look at this I mean Spotify
figured it out you know that's a
streaming service yeah they figured it
out but it was like there is definitely
some blood in the street
oh well I mean I'm just saying they
figured it out I'm not saying for better
or worse but I'm saying from like a
semi-functional like they help stabilize
the economy like yeah you know it's once
again with these streaming services it's
pretty straightforward if you want to
move towards a model that like fairly
rewards like residuals I mean granted
once again residuals like I mean that's
I mean such a small amount of the people
who work on a production residuals it's
true in fact it's so elitist in in a
sense to like make that being like the
the the the linchpin of the conversation
where it's like oh wait a second you're
talking about like point five percent of
the people who worked on this and that
that's what this all the people out
there are the signs all the news
articles 0.5 of the people who worked on
the production that's their problem like
what about everyone else you know I mean
yeah sure for the residuals Factor yeah
like oh no the actors the poor actors
like at the end or Dwayne Johnson it's
not about Dwayne I mean yeah I know but
the thing is is that you quickly start
going like well who's I don't know who's
actually who are we talking about here
because he's in the same
pool technically it's like when it comes
to categories
okay I'm gonna give you guys on average
for your commercial for for the episode
I did a Nickelodeon a one cent check I
get every once in a while
I'm done huh would you fight for that
though that sounds for 100 race
I'll fight for that bro 100 like here
here's the ugly of the situation it's
Nick you're right it's not Studios jobs
to create jobs it's their job to produce
a product and to sell it
and
I I think that there is a
like useful purpose for unionization as
much as there is a useful purpose for
industrialization
but the two
if if if one of these parties isn't
playing fair then it ruins everything
and it's a bit of a
we always try to come up with
solves for this in especially in like
capitalist and capitalist leaning
societies we're like we need to come up
with a problem to solve this the the
issue is that a there isn't really a
solve for it and the second thing is is
that it comes down to like if you're a
producer of a movie and you're producing
a certain scale and size of a movie it's
your responsibility to know what you can
and can't spend and to try to do that
wisely in a way that actually benefits
all the talent on the production so that
when you go to make the next one they
don't freaking hate you
yeah they come back and they go hey that
was fun that was cool I liked it I had
fun there was creative expression
there's new people I met we did
something novel let's do it again
but people get so lost in the sauce of
just like oh well is this movie gonna
make money is that movie gonna make
money is this what gonna they forget
about all that they forget about why
they're even doing it in the first place
I think a lot of time and I think this
happens at top levels of every company
in every industry and they stop thinking
about the reason why they're doing it in
the damn first place and yeah dude I
don't know if there's like uh there's I
don't know if there's like a union or a
contract or a political
contract that you can make to ever solve
that other than the people that are
working in those things and that are
working closest to them to be like hey
you should stop and think about this
thing
and why you're doing it and you know try
to pull some people back from the edge
maybe you know if I was deep into that
fight right now between the The
Producers Union and the unions
that that I don't know that's what I
would be doing
yeah and I'm not saying I'm not saying
because I'm not stating the fact that
it's a fact that they don't have an
obligation to to create jobs or even
save them doesn't mean I don't also
agree with the strikers and that they
there should be a
a way to do this to you know change the
industry or keep up with the change
that's affecting the industry now from
the outside right and from even I you
know what we're doing is I guess
technically moving this Tech forward you
know and might trickle into
uh the actual like Hollywood industry
that we are separate from
but like I'm an employee of a company I
think there should be ethics with
employees like I don't I'm not for
brutal capitalism but no but at the same
time it's like this company is also like
a company also shouldn't be obliged to
hold on to inefficiencies you know for
like years and years
because of that like there needs to be a
balance and like yeah you can't just say
like yeah no AI a lot of times these
things out just through
a lot of times these problems get fixed
through the actual practice though and
that's the hard thing that I don't I
don't know I mean it's good that they
renegotiate every three years because
honestly in three more years there'll be
a lot more practice behind this yeah
like it's it's it's the it's the work of
practicing the art that actually solves
these problems we can sit and
hypothesize it all day but at a certain
point they just gotta go look guys this
is good for the next three this is the
best we can do right now like let's
let's come back to this in three years
when we've actually done the damn thing
for another three years and we actually
know a little bit more because
like can you imagine if they were doing
this around like
the in the Advent of the combustion
engine
you know it would have never got done it
would have never got done yeah
it's like yeah or the digital camera it
would have never got done because
you needed to practice with it to figure
out how to do it
um so that's that's my thought
yeah yeah it's fair enough it's scary I
mean it's it's changing fast and like
dude I'm seeing this text to video stuff
I think we're next yeah yeah man I don't
know I mean we're all on the chopping
block here it's not like we're sitting
on our high horse saying oh we're gonna
survive AI but I mean if you look at
it's like dude yeah we are yeah if you
look at any if you look at any like host
house whoa if you look at any like top
level Post House they're not really
utilizing AI like Hands-On on the shots
it's more like training stuff to help
with the shots but you know they're
they're doing stuff like they're you
know to get a realistic eye they're
rebuilding the eye from scratch with the
scolara and all the stuff inside of like
people are are designing these things
and then creating these shots but the
reality that I'm seeing and I could just
be out of touch here but it feels like
the quietest one in the room always gets
the most work right the one who's
putting up the least fight is going to
get the burden of it it feels like VFX
artists are those people they're always
the ones who are kind of disjointed
they're already divided across Nations
and therefore they can be a overburdened
and being a constant bidding war to the
bottom where these houses are going Toe
to Toe with no unionization at all and
that's I mean if you want to see a world
breaker in the entertainment industry it
would be unionization in the visual
effects world and you know marvel tried
to do that I guess or are trying to do
that with their own show get released if
the VFX artists right dude I don't know
how whoever could do that should get the
Nobel Peace Prize or not the Nobel Prize
for freaking yeah yeah I mean I I heard
that what do they learn greatest
Ambassador Statesman yeah I mean it's
just I mean let's be honest let's be
honest here yeah you need if you need an
actor if you want someone to be in your
shot you just got to reach your arm out
and grab the first person you touch and
put them in there and it fulfills that
purpose same thing with writing you know
you're right all right you're like okay
I need him to say something it's like
who knows English here
[Laughter]
it's correct it's correct technically
you would look at it and go that is a
person those are words saying a line
okay yeah and now now you wanna you have
a boom pole in your shot and it's
floating around like all right or even
just like any any effect even if it's a
simple one once again can you just go
hey you do that quick you know it's it's
it's it's a actual there's like
there's there's it's a blend of a little
more skill a little that's right I said
no more skills it's much more technical
it's much more technical it's a little
more akin to like the trade school style
of learning than when you look at uh
acting and writing which I feel like
lean more heavily into the creative side
you know I mean I oh yeah especially
an actor or skill to be a writer but
from like a technical perspective here a
technical perspective the visual effects
industry has far more weight in that
category and in fact like all the
original VFX it's almost like straight
up science it is primarily it's
primarily a technical job and then all
100 people who are still leading the
industry today are I mean look at Paul
De bevik like Jesus Christ he's a
mathematician it's oh can you help me
re-light this with an hdri you know it's
like you need like hey yeah hey you on
the street can you help me calculate
like 32-bit like float light values
please I mean I could it wouldn't be
good like you know what I'm saying so I
don't know no I was talking to someone
who works at animologic who designed
their renderer and he's giving me the
nuts and bolts explanation of spectral
rendering and waveforms and how light
bounces accurate I'm like dude everyone
in this room is a scientist all these
Berkeley grads and these Mega mines and
I'm like man Megamind dude because if
you're talking about rebalancing right
we're talking about efficiency what cost
the least what's what's the most
economical decision okay well actors
cost this much set costs this much well
VFX don't cost that much throw it to VFX
if it makes sense throw it to the
effects well now we've unionized now
price goes up well maybe it makes a
little more sense to bring the actors
back because that got a lot more
expensive very fast and there's no way
around it like you said you can't just
pull people in and go make it work I
mean that's how you get Steven Seagal
films you know yeah
[Laughter]
I'm starting to see some of the clips
I'm like oh my god oh brother you just
wait this is insanely wacky man I feel
like I'm watching the trippiest like 90s
looks like a video game cutscene half
the time yep because like this is The
Flash I want to see and I'm like part of
me actually agrees like yeah you guys
got balls for making this that's pretty
cool I kind of want to watch it they're
just like very uncanny well don't watch
it till tomorrow that's so weird it was
so I love the babies don't watch it
until tomorrow yeah don't watch it until
you have it downloaded I'm just saying
you know okay we're doing we're doing
react tomorrows
we'll just dedicate the whole episode
because honestly think about like the
framing of a thumbnail
we could we could fill that thumbnail
with everything oh like it would look
like we did 20 movies
to your average viewer they click on it
psych it's the flash it's only the
flashlight it's like the saho episode
yeah where it's just like non-stop it's
just it's just a freight train oh man
freight train of flash calling babies
all right okay one more thing this is
off topic but Sam have you seen have you
seen this film sisu but the finish I'm
aware of it yeah the World War II action
film yeah well it's a great film I
watched it last night it's it's it's 90
minutes and it's just a really really
Punchy 90 minutes
um okay but it got me thinking about and
Nick we had this we were talking
via email with somebody about uh doing
something for Indian Cinema oh yeah yeah
someone reached out yeah yeah I do one I
do Wonder though I do wonder if if the
drought of American content goes on for
long enough
if stuff like this will see a surge in
popularity like Indian Cinema for
example like we love Hollywood but it's
very clear from the analytics like it
mostly hits
in India surprise
yeah but most of our views on those
videos are for me yeah
um I wonder if there'll be some
it's not going to be off the charts but
I wonder if there'll be a rise in
interest in foreign cinema
because certainly you're gonna be
getting a lot of I bet in the next year
we'll see a lot more like big budget or
even medium budget foreign movies pop up
because they they need to buy new things
to renew because all the streaming
rights are going to lapse right and
they're gonna we need to fill this with
more titles I mean we've already seen
that they're so close promoting a lot of
videos like once again we need the John
Woo crossover like we need the Bollywood
director
directing like American actors it will
be good I mean trust trust me like when
you need you need one of those that's it
dude you need you have to break with
Jackie Chan
like what is it uh a hard target John
Woo's first American Film yeah holy [__]
it's Jean-Claude Van Damme but it's like
you've never seen him before right and
if you've seen Blood Sport just wait
Bloodsport the other day and and
Lionheart
yeah and uh wow well this is but yeah
I'm no I'm down for this I'm I mean I'm
I'm well I mean it's not like I can do
anything about it but I can cheer from
the sidelines I mean guys why stop at
one VFX sequence we could make a whole
Bollywood movie we should just make a
book no
that'd be so fun though we would try we
would try but we would just be making
fun of it like the anime videos making
fun with it okay making fun we're making
fun I feel like in yeah I feel like the
anime videos were laughing together
we're not doing that that's appreciation
for sure yeah it's funny but yeah we're
definitely laughing
making fun with you can we make an anime
rock paper scissor shirt with that yeah
we're making fun with it under underline
oh god
um
making fun at you and the app will be
crossed out and it'll say with with oh I
like that I mean it's more it's
friendlier you know yeah but it is I
mean it's not like we're like pointing
at Bollywood being like haha it's like
no more like damn absolutely not always
have some of the best DPS I've ever seen
some of these films like Michael Bay
level so good they look like Michael Bay
films they are just so shiny and
glistening I'm so glistening so dude the
director of of one of the shiny
glistening ones that we looked at the in
the last movie
The Bank Heist movie yeah so that
director is making a new project now and
one another famous actor with another
huge uh uh famous I'm sorry I forget it
yeah it's South Indian Cinema there's so
many regions I can't keep them straight
but South India is the crazy one the
point is
it's the director of a film we've seen
with another Super famous actor on
another film that we've seen
yeah and so that's a big deal I'm just
saying big deal so yeah it's a 12-hour
time difference so it's gonna be really
awkward meeting together yeah it's a
super awkward yeah man we'll do it we'll
do it
that guy the the super bearded handsome
guy in through nivo so cool like whoo
man right
I know
he has everything
all these balls with stars look like the
like the Chad meme you know like the
black and white the black and white
buffalo yeah they all look like that's
that's still very you know that's still
very like Posh in in that Society you
know like being these I know they
haven't hit their Timothy chalamet phase
they haven't hit their Timber she's down
and you know what thank God they're in
the George Clooney
George Clooney face there's still no
George Clooney's next and then Timothy
chalamaze after George Clooney yeah
we'll get some string bean after this
hopefully they never get there hopefully
they never get there
yeah no I think to succeed in Bollywood
you need to be like 50 years old and
have a really cool
yeah if you're in if you're in theater
right now and you're hoping to get in
the film industry right now just saying
don't bulk up all right yeah don't do
the buff Marvel thing okay trust me it
will pay off in about 10 years
you can still be cool
yeah you can be cool and weak
but you can shoot them really cool yeah
I'm excited though so they want
apparently I don't know much about this
movie it so it's called r2r right it's
not art
r2r R r2r which stands for some I don't
think it's called r2r is it because did
someone say r2r because it's not called
r2r no that's what he said that in the
email didn't he it's called like rise to
revolt or something yeah because I don't
want to work on our RR Ripple I don't
know what it is
showed me absolutely nothing about what
the movie is so rise to rule is what
it's called Rise To Rule and there's a
guy holding a flaming torch God it's
totally gonna be a rebellion oh of
course yeah I wonder if it's gonna be in
the colonial days too where there's like
British
RR takes place before the Indian
Revolution doesn't it like the beginning
of it it's like yeah it takes place in
like the 30s Indian India separated from
Great Britain I think in 54 I think or
51. I mean the bad guy is a British guy
well yeah yeah so but that's because
they were under British rule for like
100 years the gist of it yeah that's the
gist of it oh dude Rest in Peace by the
way
um
well that's the classic stereotype for
every bad guy the last 20 years of
historical films quote it's like ah just
put the English guy in there and he'll
be the evil guy because everybody knows
they they were the bad guys yeah we
should do that I want to see an evil
belgian's very very cliche I would love
to make that there's a Belgium here the
evil intelligence too you know I feel
like the belgians were way worse than
everyone else the Spaniards were the
Spanish condensed evil it was condensed
it was yeah that's what I'm saying for
about a thousand years the Spaniards
were absolutely brutal and what they did
to the natives in Central America
on top of this guys oh you want to hear
about Leopold II the Belgian Congo let's
do the evil meter for the next podcast
so everyone
pick your civilization okay and research
your evilness and we'll compare this so
we can finally come to terms with who
was the worst all right there were some
pretty yeah there were some pretty
brutal Native American tribes too by the
way well I'm just saying I know I'm just
saying if it's an evil game of
civilization like who do you want to be
everybody's on it who's who's better
who's best to rule if
right he's never went up again
Brits like directly that's where we're
at now if you took like like yeah evil
everyone's little guy is from that
country yeah yeah yeah okay it's kind of
like it's kind of like uh The Avengers
the Mongol Empire one I Googled it yeah
Mongols dude Mongol empire were they
evil I guess so I mean Google
a lot of people you know
was renowned for taking in his enemies
and bringing them into his uh
are we redoing Genghis is this Genghis
now like
or Genghis Genghis whatever
this has been going on since the man
himself I'm telling you no one knew
everyone forgot oh so that wasn't his
name Genghis Khan means like great king
it doesn't Genghis Khan
I believe it's funny how like a guy can
be so old and there's different
pronunciation arguments over how to
pronounce it yeah was it Gengar or
Gengar is it hey Jesus
Gengar yeah I parked my car in my garage
all right I'm done
well look at this language man they call
it garage garage
oh man oh no that's so funny uh it
doesn't say about this we're like What
would you call our third kid and you
know our other kids have G names and I'd
be like oh obviously we'll call him Jeff
[Laughter]
wait are you announcing to me that
Sarah's pregnant no no no no no no no no
but I thought I was we had a really good
laugh over that one okay
if it's a girl
I had an uncle who was uh from France
and his name was Joffrey and he spelled
it Geo man they're out there wow yeah if
it's a girl you just call her Jennifer
with a G
yeah baby Jennifer
and there's Genevieve that is spelled
with a G look at that man he just pick
dude
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh dude just a little little thing
roaming around being called Yak is such
a great thought yeah after 14 it's like
yeah I've given up dude
oh wow well I think we'll end it there
boys uh who knows what's gonna happen
but we're gonna keep trying over here so
I hope you do the same thanks for
listening have a great day everybody
make it easy